c'est jean michel maire voilà je vais en
premier je suis une nouvelle fois avec
vous aux commandes de touche mon poste
avec tous mes amis chroniqueur pour tous
un physique de ouf et ça va bien nous
servir à ça avant de commencer
l'émission pour me détendre un peu parce
qu'à la fois j'étais un peu stressé je
suis encore un peu aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance d'avoir la sublime clio avec moi
chroniqueuse mais aussi le yoga voit la
tradition et donc nous donner quelques
cours d'eau y avait en tout cas tu vas
nous faire faire des exercices de yoga
avec des positions qui vont s'afficher à
l'écran que vous allez reproduire devant
nous et nous on va essayer de le faire
par duo alors on va commencer la
première position avec la posture de la
danseuse à la pression en annonçant
qu'ils veulent pas s'afficher isabelle
est une pauvre donc qui ça fait que nous
allons simplement la passion la danseuse
il ya moi la mer vous avez vous avec
leopard là malheureusement s'attendre à
la tension au pied donc on va lever le
bras goëlo rudy le front on attrape
ousselin qui va non droit qui le fait
qu'il ait fait un nom jean michel et
c'est pour ça fonctionne et on attrape
la cheville en soi oui bien sûr de
concentration totale vérifier d'où ce
n'était pas en avant et on n'utilise pas
non malheureusement j'aurais mieux fait
de fermer ma gueule ça c'est moi qui ai
fait le deuxième exercice est la
créature sauvage simplement pas ça on
est ici on valorise à on vient sur le
côté
le principe une salopette au journal
arrière à bas d'après vous et on vient
s'étendre en arrière c'est ici
zayatte hull le pied tout le monde l'a
fait et elle cassé pour l'instant c'est
vrai c'est le meilleur et la passion du
port où boeing à la suite de l'
équilibre sur les bras
c'est pas faux sûr ils devaient se dire
que la tour revient sur les bras de
christophe galtier au bras non juste
venir poser g où aucune puissance dans
les îles situées au bras et au toit bien
christophe aussi mettez-vous en vain
salamé d'isabel allende à la clé les
doigts bien de cartes et moyens de phase
correspond bien plus le but c'est d'être
détendu quand même et on ramène et de me
détendre management de penser que sa
forme extérieure comme il est comme ça
me semble hélas on les colle sur les
bras les besoins en eau et ont bien vers
l'avant et on lève les pieds décollés
qu'elle est là bien sûr bon la dernière
position
c'est sur la tête ça pulse avatar
joueurs du monde veulent faire et
ensuite biarrot va la faire derrière
alors ça c'est une des postures et les
plus durs mais les meilleurs pour sentir
vraiment bien et viennent avant
l'émission c'est génial mais je vais
partir je vous met les pieds dans la
tête on va donc mettre les bras vers
l'avant la tête est ici
doucement oh là là où la réussite avec
ses projets facilitant non ça c'est fait
moi je ne fais pas parce que j'ai pas
vous dégoûter et tout doucement le
brésil c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
faut pas que quand on traque des allées
qui veulent faire encore des gens de
sortir
non non non ça je vais pas non plus un
problème de serbie car eric a aussi
laissé bon il faut non non non ça c'est
une très mauvaise idée nivard ses péchés
vous les mains vers la vallée serré et
si vous voulez donc le crâne entre les
mains je pense m'en allais vas-y mon cas
je tiens non non eric aouita une telle
minijupe ou ce mois bon on se retrouve
tout de suite bienvenue dans les
techniques pour nulle